we'll investigative journalists at
Belling cat have done some analysis on
this video and it seems to be a video
that shows the moment the missile
strikes the aircraft so we'll roll the
video and talk you through it now it's
coming in from a westward direction left
to right on your screen you can't see
the Ukrainian Airlines aircraft it's
just too dark but it was climbing out of
drawn International Airport and you'll
see now at the moment the two collide
there's then another object that you'll
see spin off into the distance
probably the aircraft we've seen other
video of the aircraft on fire before it
explodes on the ground so moving on with
this analysis done by Belen cat we can
also look at other elements in the video
to pinpoint that it was taken in the
suburb of Tehran wesenrein called parent
which is close to the airport where the
Ukrainian flights took off from as you
can see from the video it's a
residential area the buildings and the
lighting in the video there roundabout
here match on satellite images this
location in Tehran Belling cat has also
worked out that the camera or the
cameraman or when he takes this video is
facing northeast now by measuring the
time it takes from the explosion from
the a moment you see the explosion at
the moment that you hear the explosion
about 10 seconds they have worked out
that it's proximately that aircraft
three and a half kilometers away from
the camera and that matches the flight
trajectory that you can see on this next
animation that you've got this flight
trajectory coming from again open source
material like flight radar for example
the aircraft as we know was flying from
Tehran the Iranian capital to Kiev the
Ukrainian capital it crashed
just hours after Iran had fired more
than 20 missiles at Iraqi bases with us
British and other coalition troops there
it was a state of real tension at that
time
so alley where does this leave us in all
of this well the investigation continues
Ukrainian investigators have arrived in
Tehran 45 of them some of them with
experience of the incident involving MH
17 in Ukraine when that was shot down
the Iranians have said they've also
invited US and Canadian investigators as
well but they categorically refute the
idea that the aircraft was shot down
saying said it was a technical error we
wait to see what the Americans are going
to do they might see this as an
opportunity to restart diplomatic talks
to try and persuade the Iranians not on
this occasion things have just gone far
too far so there is a sliver of optimism
amongst what is quite clearly a very
tragic incident ok Alistair thank you